what up the uh what up nick this is
daniel from tucson
now i know lil boosie turned down the
idea of getting into the casket making
business
but i wanted to ask your mortician what
is
the most outlandish or extravagant
casket you've seen a customer walk out
of your store with
you know did that thing have some
spinners on it
you know was it a translucent water bed
hitter
i'd like to hear about it anyways gang
gang dang bro what'd they put in there
with the most
extravagant casket you know what i'm
saying something with some cat toys
hanging from the ceiling or you got
you know you got something with a little
hot tub at one end of it what's the
wildest thing you put somebody in
well be honest well well most of the
time
the people that are buying your real
upscale
caskets are gonna buy either a bronze
casket
or a very fine hardwood such as
you know a mahogany that might be you
know where that wood was imported from
africa
and then depending upon the finish work
that goes into it
because you know whether you know it'd
be flat
top and you know par the finished
parkade and everything else
that's that's a very expensive casket
and then also you know they've got some
that are
48 ounce bronze you know and kind of
look like they've
kind of they almost look gold almost you
know and you can see
like some of the celebrities have been
buried in you know some of those like
um i'm thinking of michael jackson and
you know
i think um let's see whitney houston i
think was in a
um was in like a millennium that
that batesville makes and so you know
they
some places will use that as a selling
point you know because the casket
companies used to furnish a list
basically every year every couple years
of recent celebrities and what caskets
that they used
really and what happened to that list
you think
i think that you know as they've as
things have come
come on they've just quit publishing it
but you know for instance
they're used there's a company it's now
owned by batesville casket company but
it used to be called marcellus
casket company and they made the finest
hardwood caskets in the world
and oh yeah amen and so what they would
do
is they would make they would make these
caskets and one of them was called
the president and the other is called
the president
carve top and the difference between
them is the one that's the carve top
it has a lot of carvings on it but you
know
jfk and you know a lot of those
presidents were buried in those two
different caskets and so it was called
the president carve top and the
president now when ronald reagan died
he was put in a marcellus and it was
called the masterpiece
and the reason they called that the
masterpiece was that
because it had barbecue sauce in it
that casket was so big that it would not
fit
in a standard burial vault and so you
know of course
ronald reagan was put in a mausoleum
that was
designed to where it would accommodate
that casket
but you know that's that's a little bit
larger casket
than your standard casket and so you
know that's
that's pro you know you see that you
know we sell some mahogany caskets some
if we've got somebody that's going to
spend a lot of money most of the time
they buy a mahogany casket wow
because the look of mahogany you know it
looks really good oh yeah
and you know that's what oh god that's
what they that's what they want they
like
that warmth and the beauty of the wood
some people find metal whether it be any
type of metal to be more cold
rather than you know warm like woods
so and how pricey does that get what's
the priciest deal you guys have ever put
in the ground man
probably you know somewhere over 50.
you know 50k huh man and do people on
average spend more money put burying
men or bearing women probably women
because a lot of times um
you know the ma the men will care less
but
now because they will say you know
because if you think about it most
people are thinking
well you know of all the sacrifices mama
made and you know what mama did for you
and everything else and you know daddy
always said just put me in a in a pine
bat
box or throw me in the ditch or whatever
but mama i mean this is mama mama took
care of you every need you know we got
to do a little bit better for mama
yeah mama love you we got to do
something for mama mama and jesus always
loved you theo
amen man so once you get the body
you got it you got it embalmed what do
you guys what other things you have to
do to the body to make it look
presentable if you're going uh
open casket well we do their cosmetics
and of course we'll dress them in the
clothes that the family brings
and sometimes that's suit and tie and
sometimes that's
overalls and you know flannel shirt
whatever the family wants can you go
full naked or not can you go nude if you
want
uh that's probably that'd be frowned
upon you know because
you know that we wouldn't want to make
some people feel bad you know
if they weren't you know as well endowed
you know if you were full nude and you
know they'd be like
or might make them feel better about
themselves you know i just really don't
know
it'd be interesting to get a look at
that body fully nude at the end i think
it almost
would make it a little bit more like
okay they're headed they're
part of life than they are like is
trying to make them still
look alive but you know you think about
maybe maybe more people have seen you
fully nude and more
or would expect that but most of the
time you know they want that image
as close to how they can remember that
person so unless you know america's used
to seeing you fully nude
they probably would much rather see you
with clothes on yeah
yeah that's true i think and especially
if i'm going to eat after yeah because
you know a lot
that's a big thing is you know the meal
after the funeral because you know a lot
of times either
churches will host it or a family member
will host it at their house
and do you guys get invited to that or
no sometimes and a lot of times we get
invited
and if we're not really busy then we'll
go but you know sometimes you know right
after this funeral
we've got another one getting ready to
start so we don't have time to hit up
all those meals
and have you ever accidentally had the
had the wrong body in a cat in a closed
casket
no no because we take we have lots of
procedures to make sure you know
that we don't do that okay and then
especially since
you know we're a smaller town you know a
lot of times we'll know the person
and so it'll be like oh and yeah that's
so-and-so you know
randy that's randy so he goes in this
casket that's the oh he goes in this
casket
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah